So why do we need to find the lowest common denominator? Well remember that we
have to find a common denominator in order to add or subtract fractions. In our
very first example, we needed to have 90th in order to add these two fractions
together. In the second example, we needed to have a common denominator of 2ks
squared in order to add these two fractions together. Once we have a lowest
common denominator, we multiply the numerator and the denominator in each
fraction by the factors that are missing to change our fraction into an
equivalent form. So for 18, it was missing a factor of five. So we multiplied by
5 divided by 5. Likewise for the denominator 2 s squared, we multiply this
fraction by k over k. Since k is the missing factor. From 2s squared. When we
multiply by k divided by k, we're really multiplying by 1, and we're changing
our first fraction into its equivalent form. So let's go back to our third
example of finding the LCD. We found the lowest common denominator for these two
fractions, and it was p minus 1, times p minus 2, times p plus 3. Remember we
want to change these two fractions to an equivalent form. So here's your
question. What should we multiply each of these fractions by to get an
equivalent fraction with a lowest common denominator of this?